jquery is an extremely popular
JavaScript library meant to make a
number of common JavaScript tasks
simpler via a consistent api across all
browsers
in other words jquery makes your life
easier as of 2014 almost 62 percent of
the top 100 thousand websites all used
jQuery which is pretty incredible
performing Ajax requests that work
properly in every browser is well it's a
big pain in the butt luckily we can use
jQuery AJAX methods and leave some of
the drudgery of supporting old browsers
to jQuery it's important to know that
it's extremely common for developers to
use libraries to write Ajax calls there
is no problem with using libraries to
simplify the code you have to write
especially with something like Ajax in
order to use jQuery we need to use
jQuery objects and to do that we'll be
using syntax like you see here within
script is we're creating a few variables
over here each of which has a dollar
sign in front of them now this dollar
sign doesn't mean anything it's just a
character that we're going to use to
identify the fact that this object is a
jQuery object to select an object with
jQuery we'll start off with this dollar
sign which is a pointer to a jQuery
object and then within the parentheses
we'll pass in a string of the element
that we want where this pound sign
represents an ID so in this case if we
want the Wikipedia element we simply use
the dollar sign to represent the jQuery
object and then pass in a string
starting with this pound sign or hash
tag or whatever you want to call it
representing the ID of Wikipedia - links
now wiki element represents a jQuery
object of the Wikipedia links element on
the page we'll be using two different
methods for Ajax requests the Ajax
method and the dot get JSON method both
methods taking a URL and then some
optional parameters check out the links
in the instructor notes for more details
on jquery's different ajax methods